body camera footage obtained by the
intercept shows the Staten Island police
officer apparently planting marijuana in
a car during a traffic stop the incident
comes just a few weeks after a similar
one originally reported by the New York
Times in which the same cop was again
caught by his body camera in the
apparent act of planting marijuana in a
car this was in the backseat on the
floor so I don't want a cigarette this
way in the more recent incident two
officers pulled over passenger jason
serrano and a friend for a broken
taillight as the officers approached the
car and the driver roll down the window
the officers claimed the cars smell like
weed and ordered both people out of the
car the car smells like marijuana so
we're gonna check it alright Serrano was
recovering from abdominal surgery after
being stabbed he lifts his shirt to
reveal he's born to one of the officers
once out of the court the officers
demand to search Serrano's jacket and he
refuses Serrano grows agitated the
officers become more aggressive graben
push him to the ground and handcuffed
him Serrano remains on the ground
handcuffed an invisible pain for the
rest of the traffic stop until an
ambulance arrives to take him to the
hospital
the two officers Kyle Erikson a tumblr
post Ron began searching the car in
Serrano's jacket professor Ericson tells
post Ron that they need to find evidence
yeah we have myself
officer Eriksson begins searching the
car he searches the passenger side area
first when he finds nothing he can be
heard murmuring an expletive Erickson
returns to post on to a special day he
returns to the passenger side and
searches through serranos jacket the cup
holder and the center console
as a continue searching the rest of the
car the driver approaches
Sara Ericsson looks back at the strong
visibly agitated she not after several
minutes searching the car Alex again
admits that he hasn't found anything 15
seconds later Erickson returns to the
front seat cup holder and set something
down
[Music]
so overweight Erickson continue
searching to the center console where
he's already looked
a minute or so later he again sounds
agitated
Erikson shakes his head as he continues
fiddling through Serrano's jacket just
out of the cameras view of you a couple
minutes later the two officers say they
found wheat flakes in ceramic jacket you
could say as we do at the end of the
search then fist bump each other hmm
well I'm not surprised
hmm I've seen stuff like that happen
it's like they did that when the camera
was on maybe no they have body cams
imagine what they do when there's
nothing I've never been to LA but I feel
like it's the police are more afraid
most afraid of because of what some of
my friends told me I've been normal
something New York I don't play that
mmm in New York I I don't I I I'm
nervous
we got arrested a couple of times and
when I was in New York it's the stress
level is higher when and if I'm in the
state's not get arrested that's for sure
stuff like that happens here it's just
that they're more much more in denial
than in this face it's like people here
think that it's really just in the
states that stuff like that habit
sometimes what I talked about about that
to some people they're like yeah but
they don't have the right to do that
that's the point that's why it's bad
just because they don't have to right
yeah but they're they're cops like
they're humans before they're cops to
humans they're human beings I know some
people are gonna suck again with the
rhetoric it's not all cops I know but
when the cops that are in fall gets
backed by the cops that are not in fault
it's all cops because the ones that are
not concerned cannot talk the fraternity
is really strong the only cops that I've
heard talk about like that is the ones
that are not in the force anymore but
when they're in the forest he can't say
the cop for Trinity is really strong
I saw recently I got arrested well I got
arrested I got controlled
and the whole time the cop was talking
to me hmm
he thought I was looking at his badge
right here and it was like a blue lives
matter badge the whole time I was just
like he was talking to me and I was like
this hmm
I understand that your life matters but
you have a permit to kill them to do
whatever and it's gonna is gonna pass we
don't have body cams here I'm not
surprised of this you show me cops
planting evidence hmm not surprised at
all not fazed by this but I feel
powerless there's nothing I can do about
that and that's the thing that
securities that there's nothing you can
do
mmm that's how I feel cause general
public doesn't really believe you
remember when wearing that on that TV
show and say I recently there was a
report that shows day that was not made
by the police that showed that black
people were for more and we were like
duh yeah people by people are for more
susceptible to be arrested than white
people were like yeah yeah we've been
telling you this for years years
you showed me like that I really just
feel powerless if in the States it's
here as well bunch of stories that we'd
never hear about yes sometimes the case
gets chopped but you have to go through
the hassle that's tress and then you get
PTSD hmm I don't drive the same when
there's a cop behind me hmm when there's
a cop around it's crazy just me driving
the tour bus if I see a cop stopped on
the side on the side of the road I'm
gonna talk to him i'ma pull on the side
and talk fool instead of them coming at
me I'm aboard them they're not gonna do
the job of telling t things down they're
supposed to de-escalate things but they
don't do it I'm gonna have to do it but
it shouldn't be like that they should be
the one that okay yeah but right now
they don't do it hmm
I'm just gonna try to go after me all
right woman should be able to walk down
the street and nothing happen to them
but if I get get springing I have a
little girl my job is for my little girl
to come back home my job is for my boy
to come back home so I'm gonna have to
talk with them don't bother cops do not
let them do these things over there and
don't scream at them nothing they have
the right to put you on an SL and stuff
like that and we don't know when you're
gonna get out you know we have to go
through the whole legal process even
even if you're right they get arrogant
quick they know they know
cops are as cocky as a girl that things
are not gonna hit him because you're a
girl she's a girl they go get cocky they
don't get in your face they gonna say
Rachel when you're in your car that
happened to me I think that's probably
the most interesting part what I watched
it and I wasn't different but that's
what I'm saying you want exactly that
was just like the thing I took away from
the most I was like I watched it and
I've just seen so much of it whether it
be in person or on video that I'm just
like man did you know there was a school
shooting in America last year last week
[Music]
so this is weird that we're getting to
that place now you know before we didn't
have cameras and people who's always
getting outraged when they were hit news
stories and now we do have cameras and
people was getting outraged and now
we've gotten to a point that we got so
used to that but unless we could be
there at virtual reality and feel it
when the comic we're gonna need
something next level yeah for us to feel
it we're gonna have to like feel his car
that he had because of his surgery
Fibby but other than that is like wow
that was a wild ride yeah and then back
to normal it's unfortunate I don't think
that kind of apathy is good but it just
seems like a natural defense mechanism
our fault no no but I'm saying I think
it's like a natural defense mechanism
through bro like I'm tired
oh yeah it's not even so much the fact
that I'm laughing at the you know
whatever was I'm tired man I got you
listen bro you started the video I was
like oh listen I get you pee I
understand I get it so me to do roll
[Music]
you